>> Laura: IT IS TIME FOR A
PALATE CLEANSER.
"SEEN AND UNSEEN," WE EXPLORE
THE CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
CANCELED SITCOM, THE
FIRST LADY'S CHRISTMAS TREE, AND
A DEMONIC CHILDREN'S CLOTHING
LINE FROM A FAMOUS FINGER.
JOINING US NOW, RAYMOND ARROYO.
BEAUTIFUL COVER.
RAYMOND ILLUSTRATED THEM.
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
>> Laura: LET'S BEGIN WITH
CANDACE BERGEN'S MUCH TOUTED
"MURPHY BROWN" RETURN.
>> IT'S BEEN CANCELED.
IT WAS CANCELED BECAUSE THE
RATINGS STARTED REALLY LOW.
ROSANNE PREMIERED WITH
18 MILLION PEOPLE.
THIS BARELY BROKE 6 MILLION.
>> Laura: LEFTY BLUE HAIRS ARE
NOT WHAT WE WANT TO SEE ON TV.
>> WATCH.
EVEN VIEWERS CALLED IT STRIDENT,
HEAVY-HANDED.
NOT CHARACTER DRIVEN.
>> Laura: TWO WORDS: NOT
FUNNY.
>> 7.4 MILLION TUNED IN.
CANDACE BERGEN USING MURPHY
BROWN TO COMMUNICATE HER
POLITICS AND I DON'T THINK THE
AUDIENCE WILL ACCEPT IT.
THEY HAVEN'T ACCEPTED IT.
IT'S BEEN CANCELED, AS WE
PROPHESIED.
THE PROBLEM IS IT WENT SO
POLITICAL, IT WASN'T ABOUT THE
CHARACTERS.
HE WAS ABOUT THE POLITICS.
THIS IS A RECENT EPISODE ALL
ABOUT I.C.E. AND MIGRANTS.
WATCH.
>> HE RECEIVED A CALL FROM A
NEIGHBOR ABOUT A TACO TRUCK.
SEEMS THE TRUCK BELONGS TO A
CARLOS AND MARIA GONZALES,
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS,
OUTSTANDING REMOVAL ORDER.
>> YOU CAN'T BARGE IN HERE LIKE
THIS.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE USED TO
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
SCARED AND VULNERABLE, BUT IF
YOU DON'T GET OUT OF THIS TRUCK,
I WILL SCRATCH         SPATCHCOC
I WILL SCRATCH         SPATCHCOK
I WILL SCRATCH         SPATCHCOY
I WILL SCRATCH         SPATCHCOU
I WILL SCRATCH         SPATCHCO.
>> Laura: GOD BLESS CANDACE
BERGEN.
>> WAS VERY CANDID WITH JOY
BEHAR ABOUT WHAT THIS FULL
SERIES WAS ABOUT.
IT WAS ALL POLITICAL.
>> Laura: TO GET TRUMP.
>> IF THE ELECTION HAD GONE
DIFFERENTLY, WE WOULD NOT HAVE
BROUGHT IT BACK.
>> SO IT'S BECAUSE OF TRUMP THAT
IT'S BACK.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
>> YES, IT IS.
>> Laura: DIANE ENGLISH, THE
CREATOR, SAYS WE ARE NOT REALLY
CANCELED.
WE ALWAYS WANTED 13 EPISODES.
WE MAY BE BACK.
DON'T WORRY.
"DESIGNING WOMEN" AND "CAGNEY
AND LACEY" ARE COMING BACK.
>> Laura: GENERAL NEUTRAL
CLOTHING LINE.
FINGER CELINE DION.
[LAUGHTER]
SINGER CELINE DION.
THIS IS THE WEBSITE.
"TO LIBERATE CHILDREN FROM THE
TRADITIONAL ROLES OF BOY AND
GIRL, TO AMPLIFIED THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT A HUMANISTIC
EDUCATION WHICH IS GENDER FREE."
SHE ROLLED OUT A FASHION LINE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH AN ISRAELI
FASHION LINE.
THIS VERY BIZARRE AD.
SHE WALKS INTO MATERNITY WARD,
BLOWS GLITTER AND THE BOYS ARE
IN BLUE AND THE GIRLS ARE IN
PINK, NOT AFTER SHE DOES HER
MAGIC.
IN ONE OF THE BASSINETS, A
VOODOO DOLL APPEARS.
IT'S A VERY STRANGE LINE.
YOU SEE IT ON THE RIGHT-HAND
SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
>> Laura: WHY IS THAT
ENTICING?
>> LET ME SHOW YOU THE BIZARRE
FASHIONS FOR THESE ARE
GENDER-NEUTRAL BUT THEY ARE VERY
DARK.
THERE ARE SKULLS IN THE LINE.
WHY WOULD YOU PUT SKULLS AND
BABIES CLOTHES?
THIS ALL SEEING EYE.
>> Laura: IS THAT IN ANTIFA
CHILD?
>> THEY HAVE DEMONIC DESIGNS
WITH HORNS, HOODIES FOR KIDS.
IT'S VERY DARK.
THIS FROM INSTAGRAM.
>> Laura: THAT LOOKS LIKE
SOMETHING OUT OF
"THE WIZARD OF OZ" ."
>> CELINE DION AND THE FOUNDERS
OF THE BRAND EXPLAINED
THEMSELVES IN THE CNN INTERVIEW.
>> YOU ARE TRYING TO SHAPE THE
FUTURE OF HUMAN BEINGS BY SAYING
FIND YOUR OWN INDIVIDUALITY.
>> WE BRING A NEW WARD OR AS A
CONCEPT.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO BECOME LATER AND YOU
DON'T WANT FOR THEM TO HAVE A
PROBLEM OF GROWTH.
AND SAY I AM SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE
THAT, I AM SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT,
DRESS LIKE THIS COULD BECAUSE I
AM A GUY, A BOY.
NO.
YOU DON'T KNOW.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO SAY ABOUT THIS
LINE.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> Laura: THIS IS GOING TO GO
THE WAY OF MURPHY BROWN.
IT'S ALL GOING TO BE REJECTED.
I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND IT.
>> UNLESS YOU ARE A MEMBER OF
THE ADAMS FAMILY OR SATANIC
CULT, WHY WOULD YOU DRESS YOUR
INFANT IN THIS?
>> Laura: THEY ADMITTED WHAT
THEIR GOALS ARE.
THEY WANT A NEW ORDER.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE WAY
PEOPLE --
>> HER HEART MAY GO ON, HERS
SALES ARE GOING TO GO THE WAY OF
THE TITANIC.
>> Laura: THIS IS A TEASE.
I AM MOVING ON.
>> I SAW THE CROCODILE.
I WANT THE SINKING SHIP FROM
TITANIC.
NOW YOU CAN GO ON.
MELANIA TRUMP AND HER RESPONSE
TO THE CHRISTMAS DECORATION
GATE.
WE ARE DOING THAT ON FOX NATION,